>> Greg: WELCOME BACK.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: ALL RIGHT, HUH?
YEAH.
THE ATLANTIC INSISTS YOU'RE
SCARINGY IF YOU SAY THE HAIL
MARY.
IT'S THE LEFT'S LATEST SMEAR,
SAYING ROSARIES ARE SOMETHING TO
FEAR.
A WRITER FOR THE ATLANTIC
ACTUALLY COMPARES THE CATHOLIC
ROSARY TO THE AR-15.
YOU KNOW, WHICH MIGHT EXPLAIN
ALL THE DRIVE BY PRAYING
PLAGUING OUR MAJOR CITIES.
OFFICER I WAS JUST HIT WITH A --
WHATEVER.
WHY AM I CHASING THIS JOKE?
QUOTE.
JUST AS THE AR-15 RIFLE HAS
BECOME A SACRED OBJECT FOR
CHRISTIAN NATIONALISTS IN
GENERAL, THE ROSARY HAS ACQUIRED
A MILL TAKEERIES PARTICULAR
MEANING.
ON THIS EXTREMIST FRINGE, ROSARY
BEADS HAVE BEEN WOVEN INTO A
CONSPIRATORIAL POLITICS OF GUN
CULTURE.
WOW, SOUNDS LIKE FUN.
DANIEL PANTIN TALKS ABOUT A
MILITIA WHO USES ROSEERIES AS
MESSAGE MEMES.
NOT MEMES YOU SAY.
I HATE GETTING SHOT AT WITH
MEMES.
AND APPARENTLY THERE'S A STORE
THAT SELLS REP LA CAS OF COMBAT
ROSEERIES USED BY US TROOPS
DURING WORLD WAR ONE.
MAYBE THE WRITER'S EDITOR COULD
HAVE INFORMED THIS THAT THEY'RE
COMBAT ROSEERIES THAT THEY WERE
FOR SOLDIERS IN COMBAT, NOT FOR
USE IN COMBAT.
I GUESS YOU COULD POKE SOMEONE'S
EYE OUT UP CLOSE BUT IT WOULD BE
EASIER TO USE YOUR FINGER.
SO NOW ROSARY BEADS, USED FOR
CENTURIES IN PRAYER, ARE A
SYMBOL OF FAR RYAN VIOLENT
EXTREMISM.
SOON THEY'LL BE COMPARING NUNS
TO TERRORIST PARENTS AT SCHOOL
BOARD MEETINGS.
WHAT'S NEXT COMPARING HOLY WATER
TO MOONSHINE, MOTHER MARY TO EVA
BRAWN, THE CREWS FIX TO THE
SWASTIKA?
WE KNOW ROSEERIES DON'T MAKE
GOOD WEAPONS OTHERWISE BIDEN
WOULD HAVE LEFT BILLIONS OF THEM
IN AFGHANISTAN.
[LAUGHTER]
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: TOM SHILLUE, AS A
DEVOUT ATHEIST, HOW DOES THIS
MAKE YOU FEEL?
>> Tom: NOW, GREG YOU KNOW I
PRAY THE ROSARY.
>> Greg: HE PAID -- WHAT'S NOT
COMFORTING?
HE PRAYS THE ROSARY WHEN WE'RE
LANDING IN A PLANE.
HE WAS BEHIND ME, YOU WERE
BEHIND ME DOING THE ROSARY WHILE
WE WERE LANDING.
THAT'S NOT COMFORTING.
>> Tom: DID WE LAND SAFELY GREG?
YES.
>> Greg: YES, WE DID BUT I DID
PEE MYSELF.
>> Tom: YOU SHOULD APPRECIATE
THAT.
IT'S ALWAYS BEEN A WEAPON, THE
ROSARY IS A WEAPON WE'VE ALWAYS
REFERRED TO IT THAT WAY.
IT IS A WEAPON OF PRAYER AND
WHEN MARY CAME DOWN TO THOSE
CHILDREN IN PORTUGAL AS YOU
KNOW, GREG, SHE TOLD THOSE
CHILDREN TO USE THE ROSARY AS A
WEAPON, TO PRAY TO END WORLD WAR
I AND CHRISTIANS, CATHOLICS,
HAVE ALWAYS -- WEAPONRY IS ALL
THROUGH MANY DIFFERENT PRAYERS.
YOU WERE PROBABLY IN MASS THIS
SUNDAY, YOU PROBABLY PRAYED TO
MICHAEL THE ARC ANGEL.
DEFEND US IN BATTLE
>> Kat: I WAS CATHOLIC FOR A
WHILE.
>> DAM.
>> Greg: YOU STILL ARE, KAT.
YOU STILL ARE.
>> Greg: NO MARY TYLER MOORE
SONG
>> Kat: NO, I HEARD THAT FOR THE
FIRST TIME.
THANK YOU.
>> Greg: YOU'RE WELCOME.
SO ANYWAY, THIS IS WEIRD.
THIS IS LIKE -- I CALLED IT THE
TARGET EXPANSION OF DEMONIZATION
OR TED.
I COINED IT.
THEY TRY TO AMPLIFY THE AMOUNT
OF EVILNESS BY ALL OF THESE --
LIKE LAST WEEK WE DID IT ABOUT
FLAGS, RIGHT? THE BETSY ROSS
FLAG WAS CONSIDERED TERRORISTS,
NOW IT'S ROSARIES.
>> ISN'T IT AMAZING THEY SAY AR
15S WEREN'T BAD AND WE CAN'T
HAVE THEM EVEN THOUGH WE HAVE
THE SECOND AMENDMENT BUT NOW
THEY WANT TO GIVE THEM TO THE
IRS?
CRAZY.
THE ROSARY WAS A WEAPON AND WHEN
MY FATHER WAS INCARCERATED, TRUE
STORY, THEY TOOK HIS ROSARY AWAY
BECAUSE, I'M SERIOUS BECAUSE
APPARENTLY THEY DIDN'T WANT HIM
KILLING AGAIN.
BUT WHAT HE SAID TO ME IS IF
THEY DIDN'T LIKE MY ROSARY BEADS
WAIT UNTIL THEY SEE MY ROSARY
SHANK.
BECAUSE WE ALL WENT TO CATHOLIC
SCHOOL AS WELL.
ANYTHING'S A WEAPON IF YOU'RE
CREATIVE ENOUGH.
>> Greg: WAS YOUR DAD IN PRISON
FOR MURDER?
>> Rob: YES.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: I DIDN'T KNOW.
SHOULD WE GO INTO THIS MORE?
NO.
>> Rob: THERE'S MURDERERS IN THE
FAMILY.
HE AIN'T ONE OF THEM.
I'M SERIOUS.
>> Greg: OKAY.
YOU DON'T GET THIS INFORMATION
ON OTHER SHOWS.
>> Kat: NO
>> Greg: ANDY, YOU KNOW WHAT
PISSES ME OFF ABOUT THIS?
YOU KNOW WHO DOES ROSARIES?
LITTLE OLD LADIES WAITING FOR
THE BUS, LITTLE OLD LAIDIES.
MY MOTHER DID ROSARIES ALL THE
TIME.
I FIND IT DISGUSTING THAT THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT PEOPLE --
NOBODY GETS HURT BY YOUR ROSARY
BUT SOMEHOW IT'S EVIL.
>> Andy: SOME OF MY FAVORITE
PARENTS DO ROSARY.
YOU KNOW, IT'S OFFENSIVE.
BUT WHAT WORRIES ME IS HOW FAST
IT CHANGES.
LIKE REMEMBER THE KNEEL DOWN
PROTESTS IN FOOTBALL WHEN THEY
STARTED?
IT SEEMS LIKE FIVE MINUTES
LATER, THE PRO -- EVERYBODY WAS
PROTESTING.
THE EXCEPTION WAS THE ONE WHO
WOULDN'T KNEEL, RIGHT?
SO WE POKED FUN AT THIS BUT RUSH
LIMBAUGH USED TO POINT OUT THAT
THE STUFF THAT WE MADE FUN OF 20
YEARS AGO IS NOW MANDATORY.
SO IT'S ALL WELL AND GOOD TO
LAUGH IT OFF BECAUSE HUMOR'S A
GOOD TONIC FOR THAT, BUT, YOU
KNOW, THEY'RE ON OFFENSE.
>> Greg: YEAH.
WAY TO BRING US DOWN, ANDY.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Andy: MAYBE HAVE A ROSARY --
>> Greg: OR A LAWYER.
LAST WORD TO YOU KAT, AS AN EX
NUN.
>> Andy: I BASICALLY WAS, NOT BY
CHOICE BUT MY MOM'S RULES.
>> Greg: YEAH.
YOU WEREN'T EVEN ALLOWED TO LIKE
WATCH TV AND STUFF HUH?
>> Kat: I COULD WATCH EWTN.
I COULD WATCH SOME STUFF.
I DO KNOW THE REST OF THAT
PRAYER AND I WILL KNOW IT FOR
THE REST OF MY LIFE.
YOU KNOW, AND, YEAH, IT IS A
WEAPON AGAINST SATAN, RIGHT?
SO IF YOU'RE NOT THE DELVE THEN
YOU'VE GOT NOTHING TO WORRY
ABOUT.
>> THERE YOU GO.
WELL DONE.
THE DELVE'S NOT WATCHING THOUGH
BECAUSE THERE'S PRIMARIES
TONIGHT.
>> Greg: THAT'S TRUE.
>> GREG NOT JUST LITTLE OLD
LADIES MEN PRAY THE ROSARY, REAL
MEN.
>> Greg: OH, LOOK AT YOU.
REAL MEN, GOT YOU.
OKAY T